[Music]
I'm a security engineer working on my
company's infrastructure I need to make
sure I stay on top of any issues with
our security posture or deployments
let's see if du AI can make that faster
and
easier today I'm digging into our Google
kubernetes engine clusters and looking
for configuration errors that could
increase our
risk to start I'll deploy a new cluster
and clone a simple web app demo from
this GitHub repo the models an online
store using
microservices once that's all set you
can see the web app is running and
available exposed to the internet for
this exercise pretend I'm new at
monitoring and securing gke so I turned
to Du AI for some help I can ask for
advice on how to secure microservices
running in a gke cluster and get some
helpful options
back H I decide that today I'm going to
pursue the first one listed security
Command Center sounds author
[Music]
ative I'll begin at the overview then
it's time for more advice from du
AI after I read through some of the
helpful documentation rtfm that du a
gives it's time to return to sec to
check on its findings oh I see a bunch
of medium severity findings and I'll
click into them one at a
time oh wow du AI is right there with me
helping out with a plain Language
summary of the various metadata and
array of fields
below I can repeat this on each of the
findings that I want to learn about and
check on the summaries plus the
recommended
mitigations now that I know what's wrong
with this deployment I'd like to begin
remediation du AI point to me to the
network policy and I'll follow its
[Music]
instructions
first I'll enable Network policy for
this cluster while that's processing
time to learn a bit more about what I'm
actually doing right
now asking du AI about Network policies
in gke gives me a bunch of helpful info
and a sample policy to
examine I'd like to make some policies
so I'll ask du a for help in
understanding my pods better via their
labels hooray another helpful command
that I can use to learn about my
microservices with all the info I've
gotten thanks to Du aai I can work on
fixing my clusters securing my
microservices and replacing my
labels these tools enabled me to learn
more about what Google Cloud can do to
help me understand security
vulnerabilities and how to mitigate them
do AI was able to give me Cloud Shell
Code as well as helpful summaries
speeding up my
work to learn more about using duet AI
for security engineering check out the
links in the description
[Music]
below